49 zum schwarzen ross und wenn ich das
nur spaß willkommen bei neuen video mein
herz bleibt ich bin immer noch ein
bisschen krank aber gut auf jeden fall
stopp leuten ein ist nicht so der titel
oder auch so gestoppt erst mal ganz
langsam
ich fange jetzt erstmal so an also in
deutschland gibt es ja wirklich ganz
ganz viele youtuber und ganz ganz viele
machen ja auch so fragen beantworte
videos und wenn dann so die frage kommt
brauchst du oder generell irgendwie wenn
youtuber gefragt wenn ja braucht ihr
oder auch such sagen hier alle
eigentlich nein zumindest so 95% ich
meine ich würde das wahrscheinlich auch
machen wenn ich rauchen würde allerdings
habe ich mir gedacht hey stopp du weißt
ganz genau also in der deutschen youtube
szene rauchen wirklich ganz viel ich
will es nicht die youtube sind schlecht
stellen aber was man da so alles
mitbekommt es braucht auf jeden fall
ganz viele die in den videos sagen nein
ich brauche doch nicht quatsch ich doch
nicht hab ich mir jetzt gedacht komm
doch einfach mal ein experiment und tust
du auf den dass sich halt rauche ich hab
mir jetzt nämlich eine zigarette besorgt
von wem auch immer nein dies nicht von
mir wirklich also ich hab ich auch
wirklich nicht ohne scheiß leute gleich
kann euch jetzt genauso gut an lügen
aber ihr könnt auch wirklich meine
ganzen freunde fragen ich rauche nicht
wirklich ja wir meine ganzen freunde
fragen können weiß ich allerdings nicht
ich schreibe euch einfach mal ein paar
nummern von denen die beschreibung web
und so die sind auch richtig hat also
die meisten von denen ist ja auch jetzt
völlig egal auf jeden fall habe ich hier
diese zigarette ich kann es ja immer
zeigen das ist eine originelle zigarette
so außerdem habe ich die app snapshot
und da folgen wir auch wirklich ziemlich
viele leute meines sowie sehen immer so
25 20 25 tausend keine ahnung kommt
drauf an und ich hab halt wirklich
gerade keines doppel das heißt das ding
jetzt wirklich ganz ganz viele und ich
tue jetzt diese zigarette in meinen mund
und macht damit ein foto kugel so ein
bisschen auf raucher blabla und mal
gucken was dann so passiert aber was auf
youtube wo passiert ich verfolgt dass
jetzt einfach mal so die nächste halbe
stunde was dann so was sie für
rezensionen oder für rückmeldung darauf
bekomme und ich bin echt richtig
gespannt und dann hört sich das
natürlich auf ich meine ich stehe ich
jetzt eigentlich auch schon fast ein
bisschen so ein foto da rein zu stellen
aber es ist ja nur für sein experiment
man sieht dass kaka ausmacht das da
vorne vor meinem fenster glaube ich okay
leute haben dazu noch diese kapuze
aufgesetzt und ich habe das jetzt
einfach mal schwarz-weiß gemacht weil
wir das erkennen
auf jeden fall habe ich dann eine
zigarette im mund und ich schreibe jetzt
einfach hin
ja ich rauche ok kleinen moment noch
folgen das ding ist die leute die das
jetzt sehen wir dann deswegen and folgen
weil es gibt locker welche die das
machen die denken ja dann wirklich ich
rauche das ist ein bisschen scheiße aber
jolo so ok du das jetzt bei meiner
geschichte ich bin ich bin voll
gespannter wahrscheinlich schreiben wir
auch leute also freunde von whatsapp und
sowas das seil und blabla dass ich doch
gar nicht rauben was keine ahnung ob ich
dumm bin okay ich warte jetzt erst mal
aber ich habe schon direkt in den ersten
wieso rauchst du gut ich gucke jetzt
auch mal auf meine news über kann ob ich
da es weniger mache oder irgendwo keine
ahnung und ich melde mich eigentlich
okay leute stand nach zehn minuten ich
habe so ungefähr 50 apps bekommen würde
ich mal sagen und auch schon ein paar
nachrichten ich würde sagen wir öffnen
jetzt erstmal ein paar snap okay leute
wenn man ein video von einer freundin
von mir grüße gehen raus und dich
brauchst du wirklich luki time also ich
weiss ich den candy wahrscheinlich da
hat mir auch geburtstag geschrieben du
rauchst fragezeichen mit so ein
komisches meinen die schwestern wartet
ich habe gerade auch auf youtube immer
so aktualisiert und heute ist sonntag da
youtube voll ab aber man sieht das schon
so wenn man immer man aber weniger macht
und klar ich guck dich aktualisiere und
ab und zu hab ich hab wirklich immer ein
auto weniger also ich hab eine mine
abgezogen dann kam mit 20 dazu aber es
macht auf jeden fall bemerkbar
nur weil ich einmal diesen stengel im
mund hatte nokia die antwort hätte ich
nie gedacht von dir irgendwie warum hast
du nie was davon erzählt das ist so
ungesund digger okay ich prank immer
weiter egal wollte zurück so cool sein
wie meine freunde okay leute ich mach
doch mal kurze pause und dann gucken wir
gleich noch mal einer halben stunde was
sich daraus entwickelt hat und wie das
geworden ist allerdings muss ich kann
auch sagen ich hab mal geguckt dieser
schnell hat nach 15 minuten 3000 views
und einfach schon 33 screenshots ist
echt heftig normalerweise habe ich auf
fotos von mir so nach einem tag so
vielleicht 30 screenshots oder so wisst
ihr soll eine stunde abgewartet und zwar
hat dieser snap jetzt einfach 94
screenshots das muss man sich auch
vorstellen
schwarze und weiße brauchst gar nicht
herr des notars es war mein bruder war
wirklich eine schickt einfach sonst wild
mit einem joint und schreibt h wirklich
youtube hat auch jemand großen zielen
geschissen dann schön wenn man leute ich
zeigt dass jetzt nicht locker kann ich
das zeigen endlich eine wir sind zu
zweit ja zwölfjährige mädchen in einer
badewanne und die eine raucht es reicht
es irgendwann ist auch mal schluss hat
er irgendwann mache ich einfach nicht
mehr mit heute so hieß lösche mal den
scheiß alter 100 screenshots ok menschen
leute was geht nein das war nur ein spaß
hatten und experiment gemacht kommt
gleich um 18 auf youtube auf jeden fall
brauche ich nicht ohne scheiß jetzt
könnt ihr gerne alle meine friends
fragen aber es war wirklich richtig
krass wie viele von euch einfach so
darauf reagiert haben so als wäre ich so
der letzte blöde youtuber heute das war
es mit diesem video band gefallen hat
dann lasst auf jeden fall jetzt die
daumen nach oben da und treibt doch mal
eure meinung dazu in den kommentaren wie
findet ihr das dass so viele youtube das
nicht sagen ach keine ahnung schreibt
ein kommentar würde mich freuen
ansonsten dank für 200.000 autos die auf
jedem erreicht hat mich sehr gefreut
recht heftigen so viel schon auf meinem
kanal zu haben hätte ich nie gedacht auf
jeden fall
und ja danke dafür wir sehen uns dann am
nächsten donnerstag denke ich wieder auf
irgendwann abends um links hier geht es
weiter mit meinem letzten millionen
medien snapserver alles eingebettet
drei leute chem